[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 dossiers
aujourd'hui coup de projecteur sur les
jeux olympiques de 2024
la candidature parisienne est
actuellement en concurrence avec celle
de los angeles pour accueillir la plus
prestigieuse compétition sportive à
saint quentin en yvelines quatre sites
ont été retenus pour accueillir les jo
la colline d'elancourt le vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
l'île de loisirs et le golf national
pour débuter cette émission je vous
propose de partir tout de suite du côté
de la colline à d'elancourt le site qui
culmine à plus de 230 mètres accueillera
les épreuves de vtt un reportage
la colline d'elancourt deviendra-t-elle
enfin une colline olympique le projet
dans les cartons depuis les jo de 2012 a
été ressortie pour la candidature de
paris aux jo de 2024
le site qui culmine à 2 131 mètres
d'altitude fait toujours autant
l'unanimité auprès des organisateurs
pour accueillir les épreuves de vtt
la première force et l'unité de lieu le
deuxième point là ici c'est la
dénivellation et donc le vtt on appelle
ça mountain bike c'est du vélo de
montagne et donc il faut aller chercher
des pentes raides et il ya quasiment
qu'ici qu'on a qu'on a ce que l'on
souhaite pour avoir quelque chose de
très raide
donc oui c'est assez naturel que ça
vienne ici sur la sur la colline de la
revanche pour rendre ce site totalement
opérationnel pour les jeux olympiques
quelques travaux sont nécessaires dans
ce lieu à l'état presque sauvage des
tribunes seront construites en amont de
la colline les organisateurs vont
également devoir façonner un parcours
entre 4 et 6 km avec des sentiers des
secteurs goudronnées des partis en
sous-bois pour répondre au cahier des
charges
cet aménagement c'est pas pour
construire c'est vraiment pour modeler
donc on va on le fait avec avec des
rochers de la pierre avec du gore avec
avec également des troncs d'arbres on
est vraiment dans du modelage donc on
peut le faire avec des produits sur
place avait avec des gravats également
le vtt reste quand même une discipline
de pleine nature et on joue avec ce que
l'on a
ce que l'on a sous les pieds pour
construire ce parcours d'une durée d'une
heure trente les organisateurs pourrait
s'appuyer sur les clubs locaux et
notamment le vélo-club elancourt
saint-quentin-en-yvelines organisateurs
de la revanchard d'une épreuve de vtt
qui fêtera cette année ses 19 ans on a
notre idée sur les aspects techniques
mais j'espère qu'on pourra solliciter
les acteurs locaux on a des clubs qui
sont mobilisés des clubs locaux qui est
dans la pratique du vtt sont sont
également très présents et ils
connaissent mieux aller lieu que
n'importe qui ici donc certainement
qu'ils doivent bien les connaître et
donc c'est ce sera un plus de s'appuyer
sur leur connaissance du terrain
le coût total de l'aménagement de la
colline d'elancourt pour les jo n'est
pas encore connue si le cio désignera
france en septembre prochain
les premiers coups de pioche pourrait
être donné d'ici 2020
le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et déjà prêts
à accueillir les jeux olympiques seul
projet francilien avoir survécu à la
candidature de paris 2012
la structure a officiellement été
inauguré en janvier 2014
depuis cette date le site s'éroder en
organisant les championnats du monde de
cyclisme sur piste en 2015 et les
championnats d'europe l'année suivante
une expérience qui a impressionné le cio
pendant son passage
bien sûr ça à lèves le doute sur sur
toutes les interrogations qu'on pourrait
avoir la l'équipement il est là il a été
testé et il a accueilli déjà la plus
grandes échéances internationales avec
les championnats du monde donc je pense
que tout ça fait forcément des garanties
pour le cio pour accueillir les
supporters pendant les jo 5000 places
ont été construites dans la structure on
a une proximité avec la piste 1 voilà
puisque au delà de la balustrade mais le
public est juste là il peut être un
maître finalement des coureurs qui
passent avec des vitesses élevées un des
coureurs qui atteignent 70 quasiment 80
km heure sur les épreuves de sprint
donc voilà toute cette ambiance et ce
show très spectaculaire sur la piste
avec le public généralement et et
soutien et supporter grandement ses
athlètes
le spectacle se passe également sous la
piste les 250 m pour 8 de large sont
entretenus régulièrement pour mettre les
athlètes dans les meilleures conditions
ses références et donc on voit à quel
niveau mais puisque par exemple en cas
de chute on peut être amené à remplacer
des tasseaux de bois sur lesquels les
coureurs roulent par le dessous donc
voilà on peut essayer de se repérer là
on voit que bien sûr on est dans une
courbe
donc dans un des deux virages de la
piste une charpente en bois qui est déjà
marquée par les performances des
pistards tricolore sur la piste du
vélodrome nationale
là bas on à grégory baugé multiples
champions du monde qui était aux
derniers aux derniers jeux olympiques
quentin lafargue médaillé de bronze ici
aux championnats du monde sur piste
là on à michael d'almeida qui est
multiple médaillé olympique la nouvelle
génération rêve sans doute d'imiter
leurs aînés en inscrivant leur nom sur
les poutres du vélodrome après une
médaille d'or aux jeux olympiques
la dédicace sera peut être programmé
pour 2024
ce terrain vague de sept hectares
pourrait se transformer en stadium de
bmx dans les prochaines années l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines a
été retenue dans le dossier paris 2024
pour accueillir les épreuves masculines
et féminines de ce sport extrême
ce site a été choisi principalement
parce qu'ils jour je te le vélodrome on
est on est à 100 mètres à pied du
vélodrome
donc il y aura une parfaite qu'on peut
le complémentarité entre les épreuves
qui se dérouleront dans le vélodrome et
les épreuves de bmx ici sans parler du
cadre nature qui s'y prête parfaitement
exit donc l'actuel stadium de bmx situé
à côté du vélo tour national de saint
quentin en yvelines
le parcours n'est pas aux normes
olympiques autre point noir le toit la
structure métallique peut gêner la
télévision pour les plans aériens
le stadium servira donc de piste
d'entraînement les athlètes pourront
s'échauffer sur la piste de bmx actuelle
avant de venir concourir ici et c'est
vraiment tout ça je vous dire encore une
fois dans un environnement de une
centaine de mètres donc tout pourra se
faire à pied sans problème pour
correspondre cette fois ci au cahier des
charges olympique le nouveau site aura
une piste provisoire comprise entre 400
et 450 m les tribunes devront également
pouvoir accueillir plusieurs milliers de
personnes
d'importants travaux sont donc à prévoir
c'est le comité olympique qui va
exactement définir les surfaces dont ils
ont besoin notamment les places de
parking parce que comme on espère
beaucoup beaucoup de visiteurs il faudra
des places de parking il y en a déjà
mais c'est pas suffisant
donc voilà c'est tout c'est un gros
projet quand même puisque il va sortir
de terre cette future piste est
accueilli comme une bonne nouvelle par
l'équipe de france de bmx médaillés d'or
et d'argent aux jo de 2008
pour les bleus c'est 2 stadium seront un
plus dans la quête de nouveaux titres
olympiques en 2024 pour l'entraînement
ça représente
après deux superbes outils sur lesquels
on peut diversifier justement les
entraînements ce qui peut les aider à
progresser encore un petit peu plus
maintenant sur le fait voilà la compet
de la faire sur une autre piste de façon
ils seront prêts quoi qu'il arrive alors
que ce soit sur celle là ou sur une
autre là encore une fois le job ça sera
le même si la france est retenue par le
comité olympique en septembre les
premières consultations seront lancés
d'ici la fin de l'année
les travaux pourraient eux débuter d'ici
bien mais nous aurons nationale et
quelques semaines le site de l'open de
france mais pas seulement la structure
qui accueillera déjà la ryder cup en
2018 l'équivalent de la coupe du monde
du golf pourrait également recevoir les
jeux olympiques de 2024 si le dossier
parisien est retenue sur salaire des
plus belles compétitions et dans les cas
de recevoir l'énergie au niveau national
serait le premier parcours de vol du
monde andres et wall ride lkp est légion
savons d'émotion à la vie
les joueurs disputeront les parties sur
le parcours de l'albatros le 18 trous
réputé comme l'un des plus compliqués au
monde a été entièrement rénové entre
2015 et 2016 pour organiser la ryder cup
le comité olympique qui a déjà visité le
site à trois reprises se dit séduit il
n'y a pas d'autres cités comme ça au
monde
faut se rappeler que plus que un golf
c'est un stade de golf ça irait qui si
tout a été pensé pour les joueurs oui un
parcours exceptionnel mais aussi pour
les spectateurs et donc on ne retrouve
pas un goal de ce type là au monde donc
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
cette force qui est la nôtre de pouvoir
accueillir de grandes compétitions et
surtout avec un parcours exceptionnel
les routes nationales ça ce n'est pas
inquiétant car on a on a sur place dès
ya tout ce que c'est les pays mais ses
coulisses et on a un hôtel on a un
parcours et des top niveau et donc non
pour le ça ce n'est pas ça ce n'est pas
une préoccupation
forts de leurs 24 open de france
organisé depuis l'ouverture du site en
1990 les dirigeants ont mis en avant
leur expérience des grandes compétitions
pour convaincre le cio la ryder cup 2018
permettra de se roder une nouvelle fois
aux événements internationaux à 6 ans
des jo
l'effet dawala rayak à son avantage pour
n'importe quoi pour venir dans les
futures c'est comme elle à la plus
grande compétition de gaulle du monde
est on est on est très fiers des versets
wall ride cave et on n'a pas douté que
ça va tondre et aussi on travaille pour
ça
le golf national pourrait accueillir
entre 35 et 40 mille personnes sur le
site pour les jeux olympiques deux fois
moins de spectateurs que pour la ryder
cup 2018
les yvelines pourrait également
accueillir les épreuves équestres le
pentathlon moderne au château de
versailles le cyclisme sur route devrait
lui être organisée entre la vallée de
chevreuse et paris pour savoir si la
france remportera légion il faudrait
être patient
le comité olympique attribuera
officiellement les jeux le 13 septembre
prochain à lima au pérou
merci à vous nous avoir suivis pour ce 7
8 le dossier spécial jeux olympiques
l'émission est à retrouver sur notre
site internet et sur notre application
mobile pour plus d'information vous
pouvez également vous rendre sur la page
facebook de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
consacré aux jo de 2024
le lien s'affiche juste en bas de
l'écran très belle journée sur tb fils
[Musique]